[Musique]
c'est un test ou légumes on ne mange cru
un jour on les mange grillé sauter
bouillie on le mange beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup au mexique
les cactus que les chefs maria chaves
affectionne pousse dans les climats
arides ou semi arides
ce sont les populations d'amérique
latine qu'ils ont implanté des premiers
dans leur cuisine
donc ça peut devenir un aliment de
subsistance linda colette a oeuvré au
sein de l'aef à eau
cet organisme de l'onu pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture
considère que le cactus nopal aussi
nommé figuiers de barbarie peut être
salvateur pour les populations qui
vivent des sécheresses en fait la fao
dit vous avez devant vous un cactus qui
peut être cultivée dans un environnement
très aride puisque des valeurs
nutritionnelles très intéressant cette
plante là elle le casse dans plusieurs
catégories la catégorie changement
climatique biodiversité apparent nous
nutritifs et cetera et cetera lifehouse
s'intéresse aux cactus depuis plus de 25
ans avec les changements climatiques et
la désertification des sols l'organisme
tente d'en promouvoir la culture dans
les pays en voie de développement où il
va y avoir la plus grande croissance de
population notamment et c'est souvent en
milieu aride
donc cette plante l'on peut aider à
passer à travers
des moments très difficiles quand il
s'agit de l'alimentation
au mexique sa consommation atteint 6,4
kg par an par habitant
cet aliment fait partie du quotidien à
tel point qu'il apparaît même sur le
drapeau moi j'adore j'adore ça j'ai tout
fait pour la voir une si j'ai commencé
j'ai la toronto la chercher j'ai acheté
beaucoup il fallait tourner et why he
took oblige les congeler menace de plus
en plus je vais juste chez son grossiste
ici yann ans
[Musique]
les raquettes de ne pas le frêche sont
maintenant offertes dans les épiceries
latino américaine elles sont aussi
disponibles en escabèche en saumure ou
emballées sous vide
mais pourquoi les cactus malgré tous ces
avantages demeure-t-il si peu consommé
ici au mexique et une légumes comme
n'importe quel autre légume et sur les
jeunes connaissent pas qu'on ne se - le
consommateur va pas aller vers quelque
chose sans qu'on lui dise comment manger
comment l'apprécier puis aussi un bagage
qui est associé à unanimement l'apport
nutritionnel du cactus nopal est
intéressant riches en vitamines en
protéines et en fibres
il donne aussi une sensation de satiété
donc c'est ça remplit lestement aussi
puis à semble-t-il
selon certaines études quand c'est dans
l'alimentation de bétail
ça aide au niveau de la réduction des
gaz de méthane pour les ruminants le
nopal est le plus utilisé des cactus à
des fins culinaires récoltés pour ces
délicieux fruits rouges ces figues et
ses jeunes pousses mais qui dit cactus
dit épine faut savoir comment les
manipuler
ouais il faut juste pas toucher les
petits points ici il ya le spleen et
faut lui enlever le style comme ça je me
suis habitué mais même si son habituel
mais c'est pas évident ça prend
l'expérience
l'arrière le préparer lamballe sous vide
afin d'offrir à ses clients et
l'utilisent pour confectionner ses
recettes
je peux dès que j'ai un coup de coeur
sur le jus la base des cactus voulait me
prendre par les sentiments et avec le
l'acidité de l'eau arrange pour la
petite amertume car c'est vraiment très
bon pour les souks goergen et cactus on
fait d'abord revenir oignons tomates et
coriandre
mais c'est tout sauf facile à préparer
il ya beaucoup de bien sur le tourisme
au mexique est ici plus on s apprête
différemment on mélange le tout aux
gourganes cuite et on ajoute du quai
tout ce mal aimés magique
pour préparer le salon et du cactus
fromage il faut d'abord poêler les
raquettes comme engrais chimiques
[Musique]
ici ne savoir la salade cactus c'est les
plats les plus connus ici au restaurant
et nous savons aussi les côtelettes de
porc sauce vert et capte us ça faisait
un petit peu épicée c'est très délicieux
aussi qu'il ya des gens qui aiment pas
le cactus à cause de la texture qu'est
ce que cette texture le ceva vue c'est
bis q sais c'est que les gens n'aiment
pas mais comme celui-là c'est préparer
mais tu ne te laissant pas c'est très
bon saut pi2 ça donne
la texture qu'on aurait avec une soupe
aux pois legris cheese mexique est
maintenant avec fromage panne est là
mais il ya vraiment ici mais c'est pas
très goûteux non plus c'est pas le goût
qui est envahissant que non non non la
salade maintenant s'il pleut le plus
populaire oui je comprends le
qualificatif le plus précis on voit
baisser les cactus c'est vrai
le plaidoyer de la fao à l'effet que le
cactus et la plante de l'avenir nous
faudrait-il changer nos habitudes
alimentaires pomme
au québec on est grand de devrais pas
dire ça
[Rires]
[Musique]